This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. All over New York City, there are semi-clothes or nude women, and they are so baked into architecture that we don't even see them. For example, when you enter the New York Public Library on the left hand side, there's a sculpture of a young woman leaning against a horse. On 59th and 5th, there's a statue of a woman holding a basket of fruit. On 107th Street in Broadway, there's a woman reclining on a bed. That's former New Yorker Avery Troubleman. At 100th and Riverside Drive, a stone woman sits in a chair with a child. And on the very top of the New York Municipal Building, there's a golden woman holding a crown.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯 (Roman Mars)。在整个纽约市，有许多半穿衣服或裸体的女性雕像，她们如此深入地融入了建筑之中，以至于我们甚至都注意不到她们。例如，当你从左侧进入纽约公共图书馆时，会看到一个年轻女子靠在马背上的雕塑。在第五大道和第 59 街的交界处，有一座女性手提一篮水果的雕像。在百老汇和第 107 街的街角，有一个女人斜躺在床上。这是前纽约客埃弗里·特劳夫曼 (Avery Truffleman)。在河滨大道和第 100 街交界处，一个石雕女人正抱着一个孩子坐椅子上。而在纽约市政厅的顶端，则是一个手 A 黄金皇冠的金发女郎。
And these women are actually the same woman. Audrey Munson was the most famous artist model in the United States. Over 30 statues at the Met are made in her likeness and she adorns dozens of memorials and bridges and regal buildings all over New York City. She basically was the equivalent of a supermodel at the time. This is Andrea Gyer, an artist herself and author of Queen of the Artist Studios, the story of Audrey Munson.
而这些女性实际上都是同一个人。奥黛丽·蒙森 (Audrey Munson) 是美国历史上最著名的艺术模特。大都会艺术博物馆里有 30 多座雕像都是以她的外貌为原型制作的，她的形象装点着纽约市各处的无数纪念碑、桥梁和宏伟建筑。她基本上就相当于那个时代的超级名模。说话的是安德烈·盖尔 (Andrea Geyer)，她本人是一位艺术家，也是《艺术家工作室女王：奥黛丽·蒙森的故事》(Queen of the Artist Studios, the story of Audrey Munson) 一书的作者。
Everybody knew who she was, her picture was in the papers, and if one trusts legend, like all every boy had a crush on her, she was a very desired young woman. In her lifetime, she would go on to decorate buildings and memorials all over the United States before becoming a movie star, and eventually getting embroiled in a sensational murder scandal.
每个人都知道她是谁，她的照片登在各大报纸上。如果相信传说的话，几乎每个小男孩都暗恋过她，她是一个备受追捧的年轻女性。在她的一生中，她曾为全美各地的建筑和纪念碑进行装饰，后来成为了一名电影明星，最终却卷入了一场轰动的谋杀丑闻。
And although Audrey Munson's body has been immortalized in iron and marble, her name is mostly forgotten, but she was a prolific writer and penned a series of articles telling her life in her own words. Sometimes Anne the Third person. Where is she now? This model who was so beautiful. What has been her reward? Is she happy and prosperous? Or is she sad and far-lorn? Her beauty gone, leaving only memories in the wake. Like so many supermodels that would come after her, Audrey Marie Munson was scouted on the streets of New York City in 1906.
尽管奥黛丽·蒙森的躯体已被铁和大理石永恒地记录下来，但她的名字大多已被人们遗忘。不过，她曾是一位高产的作家，写过一系列文章，用自己的话讲述了她的人生经历。有时她会用第三人称来写：她现在在哪里？这个曾经如此美丽的模特。她的报酬是什么？她是否过着幸福繁荣的生活？还是悲伤而孤独？她的美貌已逝，只留下了回忆。就像后来的许多超模一样，奥黛丽·玛丽·蒙森 (Audrey Marie Munson) 于 1906 年在纽约市的街头被星探发掘。
Audrey's mother and father were divorced, which was very unusual at the time, and her mother decided to get a fresh start in the big city. Audrey was 15, enrolled in music school, and one day... She was picked up on the street by a photographer when she walked around with her mother. This photographer gave Audrey his card and asked if she would pose for some portraits. Her mom was invited too, so intentions were good. These photos were fully clothed affairs. Audrey, by chance, was picked up as a model and then in the studio, proved that she was
奥黛丽的父母离异了，这在当时非常罕见，她的母亲决定在大城市重新开始生活。当时奥黛丽 15 岁，刚进音乐学校读书。有一天……当她和母亲在街上散步时，一个摄影师在街上搭讪了她。这位摄影师给了奥黛丽一张名片，问她是否愿意为一些肖像照当模特。她的母亲也被邀请了，所以对方的意图是好的。这些照片都是穿着衣服拍摄的。奥黛丽偶然被选中作为模特，随后在工作室里证明了自己
somebody who was very good with the camera, very good in creating and generating poses. This photographer recommended that Audrey meet a friend of his, the famous sculptor Isador Conte. At first Conte thought he didn't really need Audrey, but as Audrey herself later recalled, suddenly he rose from the table, walked about me, asked me to stand and walk, and then said that he thought he could use me. But, said Mr. Conti, you will have to pose in the altogether. Posing in the altogether meant posing naked. Audrey's mother consented.
是一个非常适应镜头、非常擅长摆姿势和塑造造型的人。这位摄影师推荐奥黛丽去见他的朋友——著名雕塑家伊斯多罗·孔蒂 (Isador Conti)。起初，孔蒂觉得他并不真的需要奥黛丽，但正如奥黛丽后来回忆的那样，他突然从桌旁站起来，围着她走了一圈，让她站起来走几步，然后说他觉得他可以用她。“不过，”孔蒂先生说，“你必须全裸摆姿势。”“全裸摆姿势”意味着一丝不挂。奥黛丽的母亲同意了。
If they would have been wealthy people, I don't think her mother would have led her pose in the nude. From that encounter, the resulting sculpture was the three muses, three nude women with their arms around each other, all three, modeled after Audrey. For decades, the sculpture was in the lobby of the hotel aster. Audrey called this statue, quote, a souvenir of my mother's consent. And this was the first of many sculptures that she would model for Isadora Conte. Audrey began to work for many other famous artists in New York.
如果他们是有钱人，我想她的母亲是不会让她裸体当模特的。那次相遇诞生的雕塑作品是《三美神》(The Three Graces)，三个裸体女性相互搂着胳膊，三人的造型都是以奥黛丽为原型。几十年来，这座雕塑一直摆放在阿斯特酒店 (Hotel Astor) 的大堂里。奥黛丽将这座雕塑称为“我母亲同意的纪念品”。这是她为伊斯多拉·孔蒂当模特的众多雕塑作品中的第一座。奥黛丽开始为纽约许多其他著名艺术家工作。
As her reputation grew, she was recommended from studio to studio and slowly, her likeness appeared, mostly naked or half naked, all over the city. In 1913, the New York son dubbed her Miss Manhattan. But Audrey is not always recognizable in sculpture. Her figure is different in different artists' eyes. Sometimes she's live. Sometimes she's fuller.
随着她的名气越来越大，她被一个工作室接一个工作室地推荐，慢慢地，她的形象——大多是全裸或半裸——出现在了城市的各个角落。1913 年，《纽约太阳报》(New York Sun) 称她为“曼哈顿小姐”。但在雕塑中，人们并不总能认出奥黛丽。在不同艺术家的眼中，她的身材各不相同。有时她很苗条，有时她更丰满。
From sculpture to sculpture, there are no obvious giveaways that you're looking at Audrey's body. The clues are in her face. It's the expressions of the eyes and the mouth and the nose. Like, once you know how she looks, you can see her everywhere. It's really fascinating. I would like look at sculptures in the mat and be like, that looks like her, and then research and be,
从一座雕塑到另一座雕塑，并没有明显的线索表明你看到的就是奥黛丽的身体。线索在于她的面部。那是眼睛、嘴巴和鼻子的表情。比如，一旦你知道了她长什么样，你就会到处看到她。这真的很迷人。我会看着大都会博物馆的雕塑心想，那看起来像她，然后去查资料，结果发现
yeah, be right, that was her. Before it was easy for artists to snap a reference picture, Audrey could pose in a way that could evoke a mood. She must have been a very empathetic person. She could really translate emotion fully into her body. Audrey could hold the same pose for hours, sometimes for an entire day. And she worked closely with the artists, learning their temperaments, familiarizing herself with their past work.
没错，确实是她。在艺术家们可以轻松拍下一张参考照片之前，奥黛丽能够以一种能够唤起某种情绪的方式摆姿势。她一定是一个非常有同理心的人。她真的能把情绪完全转化到自己的身体里。奥黛丽可以保持同一个姿势几个小时，有时甚至是一整天。她与艺术家们紧密合作，了解他们的脾气，熟悉他们过去的作品。
She thought of herself as a collaborator. As she told the New York Harold in 1915. Study? Yes indeed I do. Every model who is a real success must study the work of the persons she is with. Audrey's unique set of skills earned her a decent salary, about $35 a week, which today would be like $800 a week. She made enough to give a day's salary to the suffragist movement,
她把自己视为合作者。正如她在 1915 年对《纽约先驱报》(New York Herald) 所说的那样：“学习吗？是的，我确实在学。每一个真正成功的模特都必须研究她所合作之人的作品。”奥黛丽独特的一技之长为她赢得了可观的薪水，大约每周 35 美元，这相当于今天的每周 800 美元。她赚到的钱足以把一天的薪水捐给妇女参政运动，
which was in full swing around her. Audrey was an independent, confident woman at a good time to be a sculpture model. Because the architecture that was in Vogue in the United States from the end of the 19th century through World War I was the Bozart style. And this style required a lot of sculptures and detailed ornamentation. It was a great time in many ways to be an artist. This is architectural historian Karen McNeil. Whether you went architect, a sculptor, a painter,
当时这项运动在她身边正如火如荼地展开。奥黛丽是一个独立、自信的女性，而这也是成为一名雕塑模特的绝佳时期。因为从 19 世纪末到第一次世界大战期间，美国流行的一直是布杂艺术风格 (Beaux-Arts style)。这种风格需要大量的雕塑和详细的装饰。从许多方面来看，这对于艺术家来说是一个伟大的时代。这位建筑历史学家叫卡伦·麦克尼尔 (Karen McNeil)。无论你去看建筑师、雕塑家、画家，
a crafts person making lamps. You've seen Bowsart style architecture. Virtually all state capitals are in the style. That image of an authoritative building with columns and statues all around, maybe a big dome. That's Bzart's. The style is a cross between like, stately Greek Parthenon and flowery French Versailles.
还是制作灯具的工匠，你都见过布杂艺术风格的建筑。几乎所有的州议会大厦都是这种风格。那种周围环绕着圆柱和雕像、可能还有一个大圆顶的权威建筑形象，就是布杂艺术。这种风格介于庄严的希腊帕台农神庙和华丽的法国凡尔赛宫之间。
So a Bozart building, it's a Greek temple, but then you do have the sculptures on it, you do have the Frise work, you do have all of this ornamental detail that is integral to the building. An architecture and sculpture are really bound together in this movement. When you take the decorative elements off
所以布杂艺术建筑，它是一座希腊神庙，但上面有雕塑，有带状装饰，还有所有这些作为建筑不可或缺的装饰细节。在这场运动中，建筑和雕塑真正地结合在了一起。当你把装饰元素从
of a BOSAR building, it looks weird. The dimensions don't quite work anymore. But also, the sculptures are signs of the building's purpose. They're very overtly representational. Like in a private home, the statues are of domestic scenes, or on on a market there of harvest and eating for a government building, say San Francisco City Hall. It's all gonna tell us about
布杂艺术建筑上去掉时，它看起来就很奇怪了。尺寸不再那么协调了。而且，这些雕塑也是建筑用途的标志。它们非常明显地具有具象性。就像在私立住宅中，雕像是家庭场景；或者在市场上，雕像是丰收和饮食；对于政府建筑来说，比如旧金山市政厅。这一切都在告诉我们
this is the seat of government in California, so great and fabulous, and but it's all gonna be allegorical. In a government building, you might find a statue of a woman holding an olive branch, or the scales of justice, representing the state, liberty, truth, you name it.
这是加州的权力所在地，如此宏伟壮丽，但这一切都将是寓言式的。在政府建筑中，你可能会看到一个女人拿着橄榄枝或正义天平的雕像，代表着国家、自由、真理，等等。
Just women placed on this pedestal of virtue, morality, motherhood, nurturing, strength. Women decorated the seat of power. They didn't sit on it. Why's it got to be a lady? Because women are pure. You know, a woman with a spear, she would only use that spear to really defend her kids. Right? So it has to be, it has to be female.
把女性放在美德、道德、母亲身份、培育、力量的基座上。女性装点着权力的宝座，但她们并没有坐在上面。为什么非得是个女士呢？因为女性是纯洁的。你知道的，一个拿着长矛的女人，她使用这根长矛只能是为了真正保卫她的孩子，对吧？所以它必须是，它必须是女性。
And for several years, this pure, uncorrupt symbol of virtue in the US was Audrey Munson. She was everywhere. At the world's fair in 1915 held in San Francisco, Audrey posed for three quarters of the statues on the premises. Her face and body appeared everywhere throughout the grounds. That's Erin Garcia of the California Historical Society. She curated an exhibit about the 1915 Panama Pacific Exposition in San Francisco, where
多年来，美国这种纯洁、未受玷污的美德象征正是奥黛丽·蒙森。她无处不在。在 1915 年于旧金山举行的世界博览会上，奥黛丽为会场上四分之三的雕像当了模特。她的面孔和身姿出现在会场的每一个角落。说话的是加州历史学会的埃琳·加西亚 (Erin Garcia)。她策划了一个关于 1915 年旧金山巴拿马太平洋万国博览会 (Panama Pacific Exposition) 的展览，当时
Audrey Munson was dubbed the Exposition Girl. In the quarter-four season, she was the seasons. She was at the base of the exposition girl. In the quarter four season, she was the seasons. She was at the base of the fountain of energy. She was rain. She was the priestess of culture at the Palace of Fine Arts. She posed for 91 figures meant to represent the stars. She was all over the place. At about 24 years old, Miss Manhattan had won the West, and there was a new form of art
奥黛丽·蒙森被称为“博览会女孩”。在关于四季的雕塑中，她就是四季。她位于能源喷泉的底部。她化身为了雨。她是艺术宫中的文化女祭司。她为旨在代表星星的 91 个雕像担任模特。她无处不在。大约 24 岁时，“曼哈顿小姐”征服了美国西部，而此时，一种崭新的艺术形式
entering the scene. Cinema. The obvious next stop for Audrey Munson was Hollywood. And Hollywood was, unfortunately, the beginning of the end for Audrey Munson. She is cast in a few films after the exposition, but in every case she is cast as a nude model, as an artist model and she appears nude. Audrey was actually the first leading woman in Hollywood to appear naked on film. And Audrey may have been a good model, but she honestly wasn't much of an actress.
正在登上历史舞台。电影。对于奥黛丽·蒙森来说，显而易见的下一站就是好莱坞。然而不幸的是，好莱坞正是奥黛丽·蒙森悲剧的开始。博览会结束后，她确实出演了几部电影，但在每一部电影中，她都被塑造成裸体模特、艺术家模特，并且以裸体形象出现。奥黛丽实际上是好莱坞历史上第一位在电影中全裸出镜的女主角。奥黛丽可能是一个好模特的，但老实说，她并不是一个好演员。
In a few of her films, she actually had an acting double, who would basically do everything except the naked posing. And the movies didn't end up really being worth it for her financially. She was paid very little. And none of them seemed to have been critical successes. That might have been okay for her. Her career might have survived that, but then unfortunately she was involved in a murder scandal. Audrey and her mother had an apartment in New York, and their landlord, Dr. Wilkins, fell
在她出演的几部电影中，她实际上有一个演员工体替身，基本上除了裸体摆姿势之外的所有事情都由替身完成。对她而言，拍电影在经济上并不划算。她得到的报酬非常少。而且这些电影似乎没有一部获得真正意义上的商业或口碑成功。这或许对她来说还可以接受。她的职业生涯本可以挺过这些，但不幸的是，她卷入了一场谋杀丑闻。奥黛丽和她的母亲在纽约有一间公寓，他们的房东威尔金斯医生 (Dr. Wilkins) 爱上了
in love with Audrey. Her landlord apparently became obsessed with her and killed his wife so that he could be with Audrey. Being with Audrey was a one-sided delusion. Audrey had nothing to do with the murder or any kind of romance with Dr. Wilkins. She and her mother had actually moved out of the home before this happened, but they were questioned.
奥黛丽。这位房东显然对她产生了痴迷，并杀害了自己的妻子，以便能够和奥黛丽在一起。与奥黛丽在一起只是他单方面的妄想。奥黛丽与这场谋杀案毫无关系，也从未与威尔金斯医生有过任何浪漫关系。在事情发生之前，她和母亲实际上已经搬出了那所房子，但她们还是受到了讯问。
They had to testify in court, and they were sort of dragged through the mud in the press. The so-called Wilkins case became a phenomenal media scandal as Audrey told the daily variety in 1920. The Wilkins case ruined my career. I'll never account for anything again from loving and admiring me. The public seems to have grown to hate me.
她们不得不出庭作证，并且在媒体的推波助澜下名誉扫地。所谓的“威尔金斯案”成了一场轰动的媒体丑闻。正如奥黛丽在 1920 年对《每日综艺报》(Daily Variety) 所说的那样：“威尔金斯案毁了我的职业生涯。我再也无法指望任何事情了。曾经喜爱和崇拜我的公众，似乎已经开始恨我了。”
Audrey couldn't find any work in film or in artist studios. But the decline of Audrey's career wasn't just because of the Wilkins scandal. She was, after all, totally innocent. There were just a lot of factors changing in the culture around her. For one, the Bowsart style wasn't very popular anymore. The Bowsart style came out of Europe, and there was this thing called World War One, where Western Europe kind of fell apart. And so there was a questioning about whether or not we want to be using that kind of symbolism.
奥黛丽在电影界和艺术家工作室里都找不到任何工作。但奥黛丽事业的衰落并不仅仅是因为威尔金斯的丑闻。毕竟，她是完全清白的。只是她身边的文化环境发生了许多变化。首先，布杂艺术风格不再那么受欢迎了。布杂艺术风格发源于欧洲，而当时发生了一件名叫“第一次世界大战”的事情，西欧在某种程度上分崩离析了。因此，人们开始质疑我们是否还想继续使用那种象征意义。
Both European and American architects were trending towards modernism, away from the old world BOSARTS precedents. Also the economics of BOSARTS style were impossible. It became increasingly expensive to construct these buildings and pay for all of the artists and artisans to design all of the elements of the building and install it. The architectural world didn't need Audrey like it used to, and also at 30, she was aging out of the business. Audrey's 15-year career as an artist model had come to an end, and her money started to
欧洲和美国的建筑师都开始趋向于现代主义，抛弃了旧世界的布杂艺术先例。此外，布杂艺术风格的经济成本高得令人难以承受。建造这些建筑并支付所有艺术家和工匠设计所有建筑元素并进行安装的费用变得越来越昂贵。建筑界不再像过去那样需要奥黛丽了，而且到了 30 岁，她的年龄也已经不再适合这一行了。奥黛丽作为艺术模特的 15 年职业生涯走到了尽头，她的积蓄也开始
run out. She moved upstate with her mother, who cleaned homes to support them both, as they tried to carve out a place for themselves in the small rural town of Mexico, New York. It's not an kind of open, easy-going place. Andrea Geyer went up there to talk to people about Audrey. Nobody was unfriendly to me, but there's something about these close-knit communities where as a stranger, you don't feel welcomed. Audrey could not get used to small-town life.
见底了。她和母亲一起搬到了纽约州北部，母亲靠清洗房屋来养活两人，她们试图在纽约州墨西哥镇的一个小乡村里为自己开辟一方天地。那并不是一个开放、随和的地方。安德烈·盖尔去那里找人谈论奥黛丽的事。没有人对我不友好，但这种紧密的社区有一种特质，作为局外人，你不会感到受欢迎。奥黛丽无法习惯小镇生活。
Her whole adulthood, she had been traveling around the country, studying art, working with artists, engaging in intellectual discussions, and wearing fine clothes. And suddenly she lost it all. Well, she still had the clothes. People told me that she was very flamboyant. She liked to dress up in colorful garments. I mean, I'm sure she had a pretty impressive wardrobe that was very outlandish for a small community. But it wasn't just Audrey's style that set her apart.
在她整个成年时期，她一直在全国各地旅行、研究艺术、与艺术家合作、参与知识分子讨论并穿着华丽的衣服。而突然之间，她失去了这一切。好吧，她至少还留着那些衣服。人们告诉我她非常张扬。她喜欢穿色彩鲜艳的衣服。我的意思是，我确信她有一个非常令人印象深刻的衣橱，对于一个小社区来说这实在是太奇特了。但不仅仅是奥黛丽的穿衣风格让她显得与众不同。
She would dress up on that and then part of her workout routine in the city was roller skating. So, you know, you can imagine a beautiful woman with long hair and a turban on her head, you know, trying to roller skate on a country, unpaid country road that was quite a scene. The town knew Audrey as that crazy woman who used to get naked for money. Parents would close their windows whenever she came roller skating by.
她会盛装打扮，而在城市时的锻炼日常之一就是轮滑。所以，你可以想象一个留着长头发布置着头巾的美丽女人，试图在乡村坑洼不平的乡村公路上溜旱冰——那真是一场奇景。镇上的人都知道奥黛丽就是那个曾经为了钱而脱光衣服的疯女人。每当她溜冰路过时，家长们就会关上窗户。
The kids of course were totally fascinated with her, but there was a general consensus that she was crazy, just because she was different. So it's not hard to imagine why she would have fallen into a depression. And on May 27, 1922, Audrey Munson attempted suicide by swallowing poison. I don't know how committed her suicide attempt was. Maybe it was just an expression of being somewhere at the end of her line. After her failed suicide attempt, several years went by, and Audrey's mother was struggling to provide for her depressed daughter, and she just couldn't do it anymore.
孩子们当然对她着迷不已，但大家的普遍共识是她疯了，仅仅因为她与众不同。所以不难想象她为什么会陷入抑郁。1922 年 5 月 27 日，奥黛丽·蒙森吞服毒药试图自杀。我不知道她当时的自杀决心有多坚定。也许这只是她走投无路时的一种情绪宣泄。在她自杀未遂后，几年过去了，奥黛丽的母亲一直在艰难地照顾抑郁的女儿，而她终于撑不下去了。
On Audrey Munson's 40th birthday, June 8, 1931, her mother checked her into the state mental institution. At that time, it was extremely common for families to put relatives into these institutions in moments of financial hardship where they felt they couldn't care for a person. Audrey remained in the institution into her 90s. Then she was put in a nursing home about 30 miles up the road. But this home for the elderly was situated on this little forle in highway. And on the other side of the highway
在奥黛丽·蒙森 40 岁生日那天，即 1931 年 6 月 8 日，她的母亲将她送进了州立精神病院。在当时，在遭遇经济困难、觉得无法照顾某人时，家属将亲戚送到这些机构是非常普遍的做法。奥黛丽在精神病院一直住到了 90 多岁。后来，她被转移到路程向上三十英里外的一家疗养院。但这家老年公寓正好坐落在高速公路的一个小岔道上。而在高速公路的另一边
was a little strip mall, which had a bar. And she was known to sneak out of the home for the elderly and sneak across the forle in highway to spend her evenings at the bar, ordering drinks and telling stories of her times as a model and as an actress. They could not stop this 90-something elegant older woman from running across four lanes of traffic to go to the bar. It's sadly meant that they put her back into the mental institution where she spent the
是一个带有酒吧的小型商业街。众所周知，她会偷偷溜出老年公寓，溜过四车道的高速公路，去酒吧度过她的夜晚，点一杯饮料，讲述她当年作为模特和演员的故事。大家无法阻止这个 90 多岁优雅的老太太横穿四车道交通去酒吧。这不幸地导致她被重新送回了精神病院，在那里她度过了
rest of her life. Audrey Munson lived just short of her 105th birthday. She died in 1996. This public body that once represented truth, civic fame, memory, the universe, and the stars was hidden away for nearly two-thirds of her life. But that one-third, that glorious third, immortalized her, and placed her all over American cities, perched high, quietly, out of sight, staring down at us.
余下的生命。奥黛丽·蒙森在离 105 岁生日还有不久时去世。她于 1996 年离世。这个曾经代表着真理、公民荣誉、记忆、宇宙和群星的公众躯体，在她生命近三分之二的时间里都被隐藏了起来。但那三分之一，那辉煌的三分之一，使她永垂不朽，让她遍布美国城市，高高伫立，静静地、隐匿在视线之外，俯视着我们。
I'm wondering if many of my readers have not stood before a masterpiece of lovely sculpture or remarkable painting of a young girl and ask themselves a question, where is she now, this model who was so beautiful? What has been her reward? Is she happy and prosperous? Or is she sad and far-lawn? Her beauty gone, leaving only memories in the wake. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Avery Trouffleman, with Katie Mangle, Sam Green's fan, Kurt Colstack, Delaney Hall, Shereefusef, and me Roman Mars. All Audrey Munson quotes and less otherwise noted were taken from a tell-all series called
我在想，我的许多读者是否也曾在某个少女精美绝伦的雕塑或杰出的画作前驻足，问自己这样一个问题：她现在在哪里，这个曾经如此美丽的模特？她的回报是什么？她是否过着幸福繁荣的生活？还是悲伤而孤独？她的美貌已逝，只留下了回忆。本周的 99% Invisible 由埃弗里·特劳夫曼 (Avery Truffleman) 制作，合作者包括凯蒂·曼格尔 (Katie Mangle)、萨姆·格林斯潘 (Sam Greenspan)、库尔特·科尔斯塔克 (Kurt Colstack)、德兰妮·霍尔 (Delaney Hall)、谢里夫·优素福 (Sherif Youssef) 以及我罗曼·马尔斯。除特别注明外，所有奥黛丽·蒙森的引言均取自蒙森于 1921 年为《纽约美国人报》(New York American) 撰写的名为
Queen of the Artist Studios that Munson wrote for the New York American in 1921. Audrey Munson was voiced by Kara Rose DeFavio. This story was scored with original music by Sean Rial of the band Little Teeth. His website is SeanRial.com. We are a production of 99% Invisible Ink, a project of 91.7KalW San Francisco and produced by the offices of Arxine, an architecture and interiors firm. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find this show and, like the show on Facebook, I still want to be tagged at Roman
《艺术家工作室女王》(Queen of the Artist Studios) 的自述系列文章。奥黛丽·蒙森的声音由卡拉·罗斯·德法维奥 (Kara Rose DeFavio) 饰演。这个故事的配乐由“小牙齿”(Little Teeth) 乐队的肖恩·里亚尔 (Sean Rial) 创作的原创音乐。他的网站是 SeanRial.com。我们是 99% Invisible Ink 的制作团队，这是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，由位于加州奥克兰市中心美丽街区的建筑与室内设计事务所 Arxine 的办公室制作。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目，并且当你的挑战币到达时，我依然希望你在 Twitter 上被标记为 @Roman
Mars or at 99PI org on Twitter when your challenge coins arrive. You can also keep tabs on us on Tumblr, Instagram, and Spotify. But the best way to explore that 99% invisible activity that shapes the design of our world is at 99PI.org. Radio to you. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Mars 或 @99PI org。你还可以在 Tumblr、Instagram 和 Spotify 上关注我们。但探索塑造我们世界设计的 99% Invisible 活动的最佳方式是访问 99PI.org。PRX 为您播报电台节目。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。